bonjour à toutes celles et tous ceux qui
nous écoutent bonjour j me et bonjour à
notre invité de ce matin dit albert
rufin duhamel bonjour bien tant que
refuge et bonjour aux auditeurs de
matières premières tant le rappelle vous
êtes ingénieur social observateurs des
inégalités sociales en martinique
spécialiste aussi des politiques
sociales dans les outre mer est
selon-vous galbées rufin duhamel il
convient de s'interroger et d'interroger
même de manière aiguë la situation
sociale ici
pour une société dans une société qui
est en crise de ce point de vue alors
après le temps de l'urgence sanitaire
est venu selon vous celui de la crise
sociale c'est ce que vous avancez mais
pourquoi pour pour quelle raison il est
d'abord c'est après le temps s'est passé
pas la crise sanitaire qui t'a logo qui
quelqu'un interrogé c'est vraiment cette
problématique sociale qui est récurrente
qui est extrêmement profonde qui met en
évidence de lure des inégalités des
difficultés je veux dire chronique est
majeur en termes d'accès au droit et qui
fragilise depuis beaucoup de temps déjà
la population de la ceni c'est ça c'est
ça non mais vous même vous faisiez
référence on a vécu là deux ans qui ont
été difficiles évidemment la situation
sociale difficile elle était là avant la
crise sanitaire la crise sanitaire pour
ainsi dire a révélé aussi un certain
nombre de choses et à accentuer
les phénomènes certainement absolument
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui jeudi que
la crise sociale a été aussi un
révélateur la crise sanitaire c'est à
dire que le tissu social était déjà
tellement je dire sensible difficile
compliqué les personnes tellement dépité
la défiance envers l'état la défiance
envers les scientifiques la défense bien
les médias ça dit avec déjà six volets
une rupture sociale largement installée
et dans cette rupture sociale bien
entendu tous les autres messages étaient
biaisés et quand vous aviez des messages
de protection comme les messages de
confinement qui n'était pas non plus
suffisamment relayée dans ces
populations dans cette montée de couches
sociales et quand vous avez aussi
l'appel à la vaccination on voit les
voyez la protestation
je pense que ce que nous aurions eu à
notre tissu social en martinique qu'on
n'aurait pas eu aujourd'hui c'est en
pleurs cette appréhension au
psychologique aussi par rapport à à ces
événements mais de manière bien concrète
est ce qu'on peut dire que et pourriez
vous nous donner quelques exemples que
les inégalités se sont vraiment renforcé
et notamment où il est question de
beaucoup de travailleurs pauvres
ici alors bien sûr il ya la popul les
populations notamment des jeunes qui
sont sans emploi mais aussi des
personnes qui peuvent avoir un emploi
salarié dans le privé ou voir même des
fonctionnaires certains fonctionnaires
donc voit vraiment leurs revenus et leur
pouvoir d'achat complètement diminuer ni
site
pouvoir d'achat ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans innocent ne
suffit pas simplement de dire que on a
trois pour cent ce qui est beaucoup plus
je vous rassure c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui les chiffres de l'insee qui
disent aux attaquants 29 et quelconque
d'avoir 10 en moyenne 30 % d'une
population en situation de précarité se
sont dissipés aujourd'hui sous-évalué je
pense la distance on verra bien
notamment avec qui disent que ça peut
aller jusqu'au double 1 mais évidemment
nous avons quand nous le voyons au
quotidien mais c'est pas la crise
uniquement des pauvres c'est la crise de
tout le monde c'est surtout les classes
moyennes sa douche municipale parce que
vous avez 1500 euros 2000 euros et que
vous êtes en théorie la fourchette haute
de rapport à des seuls qui aujourd'hui
ne veulent pas dire grand chose que vous
pouvez joindre les deux bouts il ya
vraiment une crise du pouvoir d'achat il
y avait une crise de la vie chère à une
crise delà de l'accès au droit et c'est
ce qu'a fait 6 a montré aussi le
défenseur des droits dans ce rapport de
2019 où il mettait en lumière les
outre-mer et faisait le zoom sont des
réalités il est vécu sociaux en
martinique et ça c'est assez désastreux
mais vous insistez un veau en
particulier gilbert rufin duhamel sur le
fait justement on vous dit que bon voilà
le vécu quotidien est devenu plus
difficile pour des populations qui était
déjà un peu fragilisé même certes
certaines qui ont des emplois des
situations sociales a priori plutôt
stable bien non il ya aussi des
instabilités justement qui se créent à
cause de sa stabilité familiale bon
voilà puis à des personnes vulnérables
par ailleurs qui peuvent avoir des
handicaps par exemple qui sont en
situation de handicap et donc voilà et
et vous noté au 10e dans une interview
récemment une entrée massive dans la
pauvreté de personnes qui avait
jusqu'ici réussi à se maintenir à flot
un alors les pratiquants des petits
boulots certains travailleurs
indépendants mais on peut évoquer aussi
la situation des étudiants par exemple
qui pour certains c'est particulièrement
difficile ou encore les intermittents du
spectacle travailleurs saisonniers etc
québec en vue d'accéder pas aux
politiques publiques vous accédez
difficilement des ptic social que vous
attendez des années des fois pour avoir
un droit quelquefois vous n'avez pas du
tout l'information et quand vous l'avez
c'est extrêmement compliqué vous avez
une carence de la proximité une carence
du travail social en proximité directe
des personnes il ne suffit pas de faire
des politiques qu'il suffit pas non plus
de faire des mesures des plans des
schémas des programmes il faut consulter
un grave des constats aussi bien chez
elle et de l'info stressé personnes
accèdent aux droits est aujourd'hui le
problème n'est pas qu'il n'existe pas de
mesure le problème c'est que les mesures
pour lesquelles ces personnes soient
faites n'y accède pas qu'est ce qu'elles
font d'autres il faut bien manger 1 donc
il ya forcément de la débrouillardise il
ya une économie souterraine il ya
forcément des boulots non déclaré mais
ça ça ça soutient une économie parallèle
une économie au culte mais et quand vous
renforcer la répression ce set et que de
mieux que quand vous dites aux gens
l'attendent et si vous faisiez saaba on
va vous sanctionnez avoir aussi reçu une
injonction aimez vous n'accéder toujours
pas au droit ou créer quoi de la colère
et vous créer la violence et c'est pour
ça que je suis 13 je suis très
confortable car toutes ces niches de
discrimination toutes ces niches demi
prix ne sont que dix noms en copeaux et
faire réactionnelle que la montait une
colère dans ce pays là et 11 ans gageons
que si nous ne faisons pas quelque chose
nous aurions une insécurité totale et
masqués s'ajoute à cela aussi
je dirais une traditionnelle dignité
aussi des des uns des autres des
personnes notamment des fois pour des
personnes qui qui je me dirais tu es à
céret socialement avait un statut social
du fait qu'il travaillait mais par
exemple des personnes qui se retrouvent
à la retraite avec des pensions
évidemment des revenus très réduit une
fois la retraite et qui n'osent pas non
plus par un essai de fierté de dignité
n'ose pas s'adresser à des services
sociaux ou à telle banque alimentaire
etc ya ce phénomène aussi qui est assez
répandue chez nous un pur pas que la
famille sache les voisins etc et du coup
bon voilà vous dites qu'il ya même des
personnes qui ont des difficultés à se
retrouver un ou deux euros pour manger
au quotidien chaque jour alors vous
savez que je suis une personne de
terrain c'est à dire que je porte
aujourd'hui une fois scientifiques
c'est-à-dire au lycée de l'ingénierie
sociale c'est du travail social de
proximité c'est à dire dans la réalité
des personnes pas dans une perception
c'est dans ce qu'ils ont et abstraite
vous étonnez aujourd'hui autres concret
je crois que c'est ce qu'il faut oser
regarder en face et pas on n'est pas en
train de faire si vous voulez en tas de
mondanités sur des choses ou pouvoir les
intellectualiser saisir qu'il disait
d'ailleurs un homme qui sauf pépin ou
ceux qui dansaient ben oui ok monsieur
monsieur carouge vous avez des personnes
qui n'ont pas de quoi manger et c'est
pas pour autant qu'elle ose aller
frapper et un problème de la famine le
terme trop fort et de famille mais de
fin à la nourriture une analyse l
alimentation transports accès au droit
aux droits les plus élémentaires des
gens qui n'ont pas de carte vitale de
gens qui n'ont pas de mutuelle et qui
pour autant sont tellement désespérés du
fait qui a dès qu un terminal qui
n'accèdent pas qu'il que si compliqué et
qu'aujourd'hui elles se sentent méprisés
parce qu'elles savent pas remplie le
document comme que qu'elles sont
réprimandés
moraliser mais ces personnes simplement
elle abandonne ce qui arrangerait les
abandonnent souvent au prix de leur
propre santé au prix de leur vie parce
qu'elle met enfin en avant la dignité
l'estiment d'elle-même et quelquefois
ils préfèrent osé
des petites voies parallèles qui sait
peut-être pas qu'ils se faire qu on voit
effectivement continuer
sempiternellement à vouloir accéder à un
droit qui malheureusement recule chaque
fois qu'elle s'avance du système d aussi
beaucoup donc vous le dites la
débrouillardise beaucoup pour certains
qui n'ont pas d'autre choix alors c'est
vrai que ça on l'a dit ça a été
accentuée que le problème de d'épidémie
de pandémie oui mais donc ça c'était
congio conjoncturel mais vous dites que
les inégalités en martinique sont
structurels wii
développé il vous plaît très bien sûr
parce que j'attendais il faut pas non
plus on est on est quand même dans ces
deux territoires ultramarins dans une et
ça fait pas si longtemps que nous avions
un statut que le dit hein c'est 46 je
pense que ce pays il est encore à
décoloniser il s'agit assume
parfaitement quand je le dis c'est à
dire qu'on ne peut pas rejouer dû penser
des politiques sociales comme on ne
penserait à como et pense à paris on
connaît pas un autre où on y passe
ailleurs je pense qu'il faut les adapter
c'est vrai que la république est une
république une indivisible et peut-être
sociale quand elle se veut une
indivisible sociale et doit rassembler
et ce rassemblement ce n'est pas créer
des politiques publiques c'est permettre
aux personnes pour lesquelles ces
politiques publiques soient créés d'y
accéder et c'est ce que nous disons
aujourd'hui ce que nous voulons ce rôle
alors il serait sage en proximité
l'institution qu'est ce que vous
préconisez alors je crois que vous vous
dites par exemple un observatoire de la
pauvreté c'est ça je trouve cela semble
si oui oui non mais voilà je suis allé
plus loin oui c'est ça c'est ça agir en
proximité ça veut dire prendre prendre
le temps de rencontrer ces couches
sociales pendant le temps des concret
les dispositifs pour cela aussi des
dispositifs de terrain pas de bragon
craignant que pour vous renseigner les
personnes accompagnées jeu même coque
assisté supplier et plus restituer la
dignité et l'autonomie de toutes les
couches sociales je crois que c'est
quand je le dis parce que je
ne peux pas être passifs envoyant chaque
jour augmenté d'un point de pain trois
points la mise et à la détresse la
paupérisation je pense qu'à un moment il
faut comprendre que cette population si
elle souffre si elle est éloignez les
systèmes si elles n'acceptent pas au
droit si elle a des inégalités si
aujourd'hui un cri ce désarroi vous avez
bien vu le résultat des votes ce n'est
pas glorieux nous savons bien faire
quand nous avons des campagnes notamment
municipales passées dans les quartiers
etc il faut aujourd'hui regarder de face
notre population dans toutes ses
diversités et plus osé lui dire
aujourd'hui que nous sommes là justement
pour qu'elle accède un peu davantage
d'euros mais en disant cela vous vous
adressez à qui à l'ensemble des pouvoirs
publics tout le monde doit se mettre
ensemble 1 6 2 oui donc ce
qui représente l'état les élus à la ctn
dans les
catégories qui prétendent avoir des
politiques publiques et des politiques
sociales à destination des
martiniquaises et des martiniquais
devrait être sur le terrain pour qu'elle
accepte
donc une sorte de task force pour lutter
contre une entité politique publique
devrait avoir son relais de terrain
merci guy albert rufin duhamel
évidemment on pourrait en dire encore
plus mais